alright alright new game against my arm
against here International Master gone
yeah well i played him a couple of times
and his yeah more it's the kind of guy
who put place on time every position so
need to be aware of this all right h3 is
a pretty rare move here ideas to play
g4g for Bishop g2 this kind of setup
yeah I want to prevent down b5 for a
while at least okay so he wants to use
those those somewhat to weaken to our
squares okay I could play a form FYI
maplin night g6 you would be include be
an interesting setup what else is there
i could I could bring 1i to f5 myself
also an idea
maybe try to fly anyway
yeah maybe this night h4s really are
really annoying okay I need to I think
take here the question is what is how to
assess this kind of position here first
sight it looks very good for black
because of those dark squared weaknesses
but maybe I have some chances to UM to
use on my somewhat better development
here we need to take am flow in order to
try that how can I expect it to take
more but this is so maybe better okay
so sharply six here yeah I guess it it
should be helpful to them to have a poor
96 ok this night h4 movers somewhat
somewhat annoying
okay maybe I can get the knight to f3
here now it's not not exactly a great
position to some quite a weakened this
this whole structure
don't really want to exchange notes not
a choice really am maybe I can cancel I
intended to Castle when we should be six
Bishop ii 3v3 was played to prevent nazi
form ok wants to get rid of the dark
squared bishop ok so that's
understandable
yes I said first impression is that
black is doing great here but it's not
not that easy to to improve the position
need to catch up a bit en time yeah what
about exchanging the rookie I'm suddenly
not what I love to do but I'm not sure
that I can avoid it in the long run so i
might as well get ahead with this
yeah of course the issue is my bishop
here this is quite an ugly piece on to
play Bishop f1 um ok to go here if you
take c5 I can play a night b3 and detect
a 5 myself I'll see 5 9 p-5 is also not
not bad
yeah the position is slightly vary some
it's not okay what about nine to be
three taking a five and c5 you can take
here 9 a-5 take see to all ready for us
hanging at the end
okay yeah how to take no time warning
you don't want them taking what the pawn
would give him give him the apron which
is most likely more dangerous then might
be porn the only real weakness here see
a five-pound want to go dt 2 2 b 3
taking a five and c5 somebody's got two
nights for one square on e5 and this
might help me find this Bishop is so
awful anymore it's not great of course
but i'll add you five
drop back to d2 to be three
not quite sure how bad this is I mean
I'm worse but not quite sure how much
fighters left in the position I didn't
really pay attention to that I mean that
you can cover here simply but if i get
the apron it shouldn't be too bad that
if I have to to have seven now
yeah now I'm even better here unless I'm
really overlooking something simple okay
better sir bit optimistic
doesn't look like I should lose really
gained ground yeah this was some defense
from very early on i guess i miss played
this opening I mean this is not an
uncommon setup what I what I did here
this is G for stuff but this move really
am yeah I guess my reaction boss wasn't
too great but it's not not a bad idea to
get the night to g6 those f4 f4 and oops
this f4 Square + H 4th grade he got a
very nice position here here only black
hand can play for something and you
really had something not quite sure why
he gave it away and after a while it was
not quite sure how this is to be
assessed maybe this is still ok hard to
tell you how to tell at least they have
some slight counter play against a five
but it's not not not a nice position to
have alright thanks for watching